من جهته قال زعيم المعارضه الاسرائيليه يا
اير لابيد ان اسرائيل لا تفعل ما يكفي حتى
يعود المخطوفون من غزه الى الوطن وفق
تعبيره واضاف ان استعادتهم يجب ان تكون
اولويه الحكومه متعهدا بتوجيه دعم
المعارضه لاي صفقه تبادل يتم التوصل
اليها المخطوفون يجب ان نعيدهم الى الوطن
الان هذا ما يقوم به الطرف القوي ونحن
الاقوى الطرف القوي يحدد لنفسه اولويات
وبالنسبه لاسرائيل اعاده المخطوفين هي
المهمه الاكثر الحاحا الامر يتعلق بالحياه
او الموت سنفعل كل شيء من اجل اعادتهم
جميعا قلت لرئيس الوزراء واقول من هذا
المنبر المعارضه ستؤيد كل تحرك وكل صفقه
فعلنا ذلك في الصفقه الاولى ولم تسمعوا
منا اي كلمه انتقاد واقول للحكومه لن نصعب
عليكم اذا حققتم صفقه جديده ولن نقول انكم
اضررت باهداف الحرب اذا مكن ذلك من اعاده
المخطوفين الى
الوطن